[Applause]
wow thank you very much and you have a
record crowd here today so that's a
building that's not exactly brand new it
looks like
but the crowd is record and uh that's a
long time and thank you very much and to
the Fire Marshals and fire department
and police and everybody else involved a
lot of people outside that couldn't get
in I want to thank everybody
and also to Chairman Schaefer for the
tremendous leadership over the past four
years
thank you to
the great state of Georgia we love
Georgia we love Georgia
great place great place keep America
great again he just
it's a great state we're also thrilled
to be joined by the nrcc chairman
Congressman Richard Hudson where is
Richard he's around here someplace he is
fantastic hello Richard oh there he is
we'll go into his state in a couple of
minutes you know we're going to be here
and we're going to North Carolina and
that'll be great but Richard
congratulations on a great job in
addition today I'm honored to receive
the endorsements of some really
incredible people Patriots I would call
them Georgia Patriots
including Representatives Mike Collins
where's Mike where's Mike
thank you Mike
great person thank you very much
and also Andrew Clyde and Marjorie
Taylor green thank you for those
endorsements
[Applause]
thank you very much for those
endorsements and uh we love you people
that's a great group of Patriots and
speaking of Patriots and I met his
father I love his father too his father
was
really the man that gave him those genes
according according to the world but I
think the mother probably had an even
bigger impact Bert Jones lieutenant
governor Bert Jones
and uh it comes from a Incredible family
but Bert's done a fantastic job and he's
going places he's going I've been saying
that for a long time and I've so far
I've been right he's doing very popular
and doing a great job as lieutenant
governor Public Service commissioner the
first person in this state to endorse me
Bubba McDonald
where's Bubba very thank you Bubba
and I like your jacket Bubba
I also uh want to thank very much he's
always been there a real powerful strong
person and a man who loves your state
and loves our country state senator
Brandon Beach
thank you Brandon thank you Brandon
he's a great guy
for seven years we've been engaged in an
epic struggle to rescue our country from
the Sinister forces women who hate it
they hate our country and who want to
destroy it can be no other reason
these forces are far stronger than
Russia China North Korea and Iran all
put together think of that from within
is worse than from without
because the Right leader in America if
you have that leader you can have no
problems with those countries we had no
problems we got it all straightened out
they understood would have never ever
had the problem with Russia Ukraine
China right now is looking like they're
going to do something and they would
have never even talked about it right
now however they're putting us
in the most dangerous position in the
history of our country and that's to a
large extent because of the kind of
Weaponry we're talking that we're
talking about together we stand up to
the globalists we stand up to marxists
we stand up to the Rhinos you know the
rhinos are
pretty bad
because with the Rhinos you don't
exactly know where they're coming from
the others you know but with the Rhinos
sometimes you find out and we got to
stand up to the Rhinos Communists and
environmental extremists you know you
have environmental extremists too
we stand up to the open borders Fanatics
the radical left Democrats they're
Lawless
partisan prosecutors the prosecutors
every time I fly over a blue State I get
a subpoena
we want him before the grand jury
[Applause]
and we stand up to the fake news media
which is seriously bad
and on November 5th 2024 we're going to
stand up
to the corrupt political establishment
we're going to evict a totally corrupt
President Joe Biden from the White House
and we're going to finish the job that
we started the most successful
presidency
thank you
and I think as everybody in this
absolutely packed house knows I've put
everything on the line and I will never
yield I never yield
I will never be deterred I will never
stop fighting for you I didn't need this
I had a great life
uh people said would you do it again the
answer is yes because we're going to
make America great again we had it there
and then bad things happened
bad things happened with an election
right declared bad bad things happened
but we're going to make it uh great like
never before I really believe that with
your vote we will take back our country
from these fascists and Thugs and we
will absolutely make America great again
from the beginning our America First
agenda has been an existential threat to
the rotten political class that gets
rich and Powerful at your expense
erasing our borders cheating on
elections exporting our jobs and
squandering our blood and treasure on
endless Foreign Wars
we were out of all our Wars everybody
said when I got elected remember oh his
personality you're going to have wars
you're going to be fighting the whole
world and it just worked out the
actually it was my personality that
didn't want to make people fight
it is sort of reverse
first time in 70 years that this has
happened we started no Wars we finished
some we defeated the Isis caliphate 100
percent and many other things we've
rebuilt our military of course they gave
a lot of it away didn't they huh
they gave a lot of our military away to
Afghanistan if you can even believe it
Afghanistan is now one of the largest
exporters of Military Arms they sell the
things that we gave to them 85 billion
dollars we lost 13 soldiers many very
horrifically wounded and we left many
Americans behind
they moved out the military first now it
was supposed to be the opposite you move
out the military last
they've launched one hoax and Witch Hunt
after another to try and stop our
movement and thwart the will of the
American people every time you not even
believable Witch Hunt Witch Hunt scam
hoax
it's called election interference and
they're doing the best they can with it
because who the hell would vote for them
with the policies that they have of open
borders and no voter ID
as the Durham report which just came out
proved they spied in my campaign think
of it can you imagine if it was the
other way around
they spied on my campaign and we caught
them
they forged false evidence to get
illegal surveillance warrants the FBI
offered one million dollars for a
fictitious dossier written by a foreign
spy to try to frame me for treason they
were now they're trying to do it again
these people don't stop and they're bad
and we have to get rid of them we have
to get rid of them fast
they put our country through hell
and they knew it was all a lie the
entire time they knew it was a lie
remember it's not me they're going after
it's somebody else and that person will
not be able to withstand the fire if
it's not me you know it'll be somebody
else they're not going to withstand that
far because that fire doesn't stop just
with me that fire is going to go on
against any conservative any Republican
anybody other than them
because they want the power but they
actually want to destroy our country I
believe that because there could be no
other reason
but I know them all and they uh in many
cases even admit it they come up they
say how do you take it
we take it and we fight back like
nobody's ever fought before
think of it
think of it we had Russia Russia Russia
right total fake
all came out now fake it was all made up
by Hillary Clinton the dossier was by
Clinton and others the Democratic party
DNC
so we had Russia Russia Russia Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine the no collusion Mueller
Witch Hunt they found after two and a
half years there was no collusion
impeachment hoax number one perfect
phone call
impeachment hoax number two the illegal
censorship of the Hunter
Biden laptop from Hell remember the
laptop from hell
remember that where the 51 intelligence
officials falsely said that it was
Russian disinformation
everybody knew that wasn't too they knew
it wasn't true that's become a big
Scandal that was another form of
cheating on the election a lot of the
great pollsters we have a couple of them
here tonight they said that the I mean
you look at what they said about it 17
point difference it's uh incredible but
the 51 intelligence agents lied
now the Marxist left is once again using
the same corrupt doj and the same
corrupt FBI
and the attorney general and the Local
District Attorneys to interfere
in our elections at a level that our
country and few countries have ever seen
before
they're cheating they're crooked they're
corrupt these criminals cannot be
rewarded they must be defeated you have
to defeat them
have to deceiving
because in the end they're not coming
after me they're coming after you and
I'm just standing in their way here I am
I'm standing in their way and I always
will be
thank you very much
the ridiculous and baseless indictment
of Me by the Biden administration's
weaponized Department of Injustice
will go down is among the most horrific
abuses of power in the history of our
country many people have said that
Democrats have even said it this vicious
persecution is a travesty of Justice
you're watching Joe Briden job I think
of it Biden is trying to jail his
leading political opponent an opponent
that's beating him by a lot in the polls
just like they do in stalinist Russia or
communist China no different
our country has gone very bad and think
of it in three years three years ago we
were energy independent we had no
inflation
we had low taxes we had low interest
rates we had the greatest economy in
history
think of it I could stand up here all
day long and just talk about all of the
great success we had and now
we have everything's the opposite
inflation's killing our country energy
is
ridiculous and ridiculously how we're
getting energy from Venezuela
nobody can even believe it I never
thought
such a thing could happen to America
as far as the
joke of an indictment it's a horrible
thing it's a horrible thing for this
country
I mean the only good thing about it is
it's driven my poll numbers way up can
you believe this well
now it's driven up way up and uh
somebody said the fundraising is through
the roof that's less important but I
will tell you it's really driven us
right through the sky
we're really winning big we're winning
by every we're beating the hell out of
the Republicans and we're beating the
hell out of Joe Biden that's why they're
doing it if I wasn't let me tell you if
I wasn't there'd be no Witch Hunt
there'd be no indictment if I was losing
we're winning by a lot against the
Democrats if I were losing you know
they're the party of disinformation they
say oh oh we want to run against Trump
we want to run so badly against Trump we
won the first time and that we did
better the second time that we did the
first time we won by many millions of
more votes much better not even close
we got the most votes ever in the
history of our country and today we're
more popular than we were in 2020 we're
going to get numbers that are absolutely
incredible
federal law enforcement
should never have been involved in this
matter
but they got involved
and we just can't let that happen they
got involved with Twitter they got
involved with Facebook
the pollsters say it made maybe a 17
point difference
and then they say I lost we didn't lose
we won by a lot but they say I lost by
20 000 votes
twenty thousand nuts
you know we'd come here for rallies we'd
come to other states for rallies but
would come into Georgia for a rally with
a 40 50 000 people they'd come in for a
rally they'd have eight they couldn't
fill up the circles and then you hear he
clipped you at the end just clipped you
didn't happen we won Alabama in a record
number we won South Carolina in a record
number those people that run at the
professional say it's not possible to
win Alabama in a record South Carolina
in a record
and lose Georgia just by a tiny little
bit you know
so you got to watch that you got to
watch it we're all going to be watching
it is President all of my documents fell
under what is known as the presidential
records act which is not at all a
criminal act everything it's all judged
by the presidential records act in this
whole fake indictment they don't even
once mention
the presidential records act which is
really the ruling Act
which this case falls under 100 percent
because they want to use something
called the Espionage Act doesn't that
sound terrible oh Espionage we got a box
I got a box
the Espionage
the Espionage Act of 1917.
I think was put in there about World War
One
boxes and by the way Biden's got 1850
boxes he's got boxes in Chinatown DC
he's got boxes all over the place he
doesn't know what the hell to do with
him and he's fighting them on the boxes
he doesn't want to give the boxes and
then they say Trump is obstructioning
he's obstructing
now it's a sad uh sad day for the
country you know I said
last night I said that uh
our country has tears
because of what's Happening we have fake
elections we have no borders we have
inflation we have everything it's just
going wrong
there's never been anything like it in
the history of our country we've never
done like this
and the division is so bad because what
they do is so bad
and our people are angry and they just
keep doing it and sometimes you need
strength you have to have strength more
than just normal strength and we have to
get a change because we're not going to
have a country left remember I used to
campaign and I'd say that we're going to
end up being Venezuela on steroids and
that's exactly what's happening to our
country our country is going to hell
I was going to change the name of our
campaign to keep
America great now that's not as good as
Maga
mag is Maga right Maga
and keep America greatest KAG I don't
think tag is never going to compete with
Maga but we couldn't say keep America
great because our country is not great
we're laughed at all over the world
we're no longer respected three years
ago we were respected like our country
has never been respected before
they also don't mention the defining
lawsuit that was brought against Bill
Clinton
and it was lost by the government the
famous Sox case
that says he can keep his documents they
don't mention that they don't these are
Minor Details
and that's the ruling law
when I left office and was moving to
Florida boxes were openly
sitting on the White House sidewalk
everybody was taking pictures of them
this isn't somebody smuggling boxes out
pictures of them you've all seated
sitting with people from GSA and other
people waiting to put them on a truck
but they were literally sitting outside
of the White House
waiting for a truck to come then the
truck come it was at for a long time and
they put it in and they brought it down
to Florida
and they make it sound like it's a big
if that's a spy operation or if that's
something bad we did a very poor job I
will tell you
first thing you learn is don't put them
on the sidewalk in front of the White
House
as a former president we were
negotiating with the National Archives
and Records Administration just as every
other president has done
and the next thing I knew Mar-A-Lago was
raided by gun toting FBI agents we were
negotiating
[Applause]
and again meanwhile Biden has troves of
classified documents from his time as
vice president which is much tougher
actually it's actually a much tougher
standard
and even as a senator
and the Senators are not allowed to
bring classified documents and I heard
a senator named Dick Durbin you ever
hear of happens to be a Democrat he was
beside himself he couldn't believe that
Biden took classified documents as a
senator it's a No-No a real no no can't
do it
I was amazed that I saw him I'm sure he
changed his tune you know when he got
the hell beat out of him when he went
back into his beautiful marble clad
office
many of Biden's documents were in
Chinatown and many of them were places
that you don't want to have documents
but I hear how wonderful he did think of
it
1850 boxes he had
minus peanuts but you saw mine because
they were on that sidewalk
and they paid over
the million dollars a year
and they're still you know he was paid
by China really
because China makes a big payment to
the area where he has
the vast preponderance of documents
and he makes about a million dollars a
year paid by China
and these documents were strewn all over
the place and then he has
document strewn on his garage floor
where he has the now famous Corvette you
know with that story his beautiful
Corvette
there was no security there they had a
garage door that you could cut it with a
scissor they didn't have Secret Service
I have Secret Service all over
Mar-A-Lago and Marla goes strong and
powerful it was built it was actually
built by Marjorie Merriweather Post and
EF Hutton
remember
wheneverton speaks people listen well
they
one of the greatest ads ever but they
built it and it was built as the
southern white house actually
and Jimmy Carter gave it up he said it
was too expensive to be borne by it I
was I said thank you very much we have
to get that
thank you Jimmy thank you very much
but that was actually built as a
southern white house that's very
powerful but we have great people secret
Services all over the place and that's
the way we like it but unlike me who had
absolute declassification Authority as
President Biden didn't have any
Authority and he had no right to possess
those documents none whatsoever yet
nothing happened to Crooked Joe with all
that many many many times
what we have and you know uh there was
an article recently that all presidents
take documents out they bring them out
all of them virtually every one of them
in Fairly modern times if you look at
Hillary Clinton set up a illegal private
serve in her basement specifically to
break public disclosure laws and that
would expose her and her family's
finances she stored vast quantities of
classified and sensitive information
some of it leaking into Anthony Weiner
you remember him computer Anthony Weiner
that was a real Beauty
but much of it went into Anthony
Weiner's computer that's probably the
last I'm not sure I think I'd rather
have it on
Hunter Biden's computer than Anthony
Weiner's computer
and when caught Hillary deleted an acid
washed
33 000 emails in defiance of a
congressional subpoena she already had
the subpoena and her age smashed and
destroyed iPhones with a hammer
yet the FBI and doj protected her they
did absolutely nothing in Hillary's case
the FBI and doj largely
did not issue subpoenas
they did not use a grand jury they did
not execute search warrants and Comey
declared that there was
no problem he said no reasonable
prosecutor would ever bring a case like
that she knocked out 33 000
emails
and Hillary wasn't indicted
she should have been
but she wasn't indicted she was
protected by the Democrats Biden was not
indicted and what he's done is terrible
you know they like to say well what
Trump did
I mean actually I thought it was I was
impressed I looked I looked so orderly
and nice somehow somebody turned over
one of the boxes did you see that I said
I wonder who did that did the FBI do
that because they also did something
where they put documents all over the
floors and they took pictures and they
tried to pretend like I did it and then
they had to apologize they did it
remember that famous picture but the box
that was turned over
it had newspapers it had pictures it had
clippings it had all sorts of things
nobody saw any
documents there
only
Donald Trump is indicted and they take
one charge and they turn it into 36
charges
you saw that everybody was amazed
lawyers on television yes they're not
usually the best lawyers but some are
very good they're saying we've never
seen anything like it they took one
charge and they made it 36 different
times
and we have a thug who's in charge this
is
a political hit job
Republicans are treated far differently
at the justice department than Democrats
these are the same people who cause the
lowest learning catastrophe
that's just deranged
Jack you know you know I'm talking about
Jack Smith what do you think his name
used to be I don't know does anybody
Jackson sounds so innocent he's deranged
but he's the one that caused the lowest
learner catastrophe with the IRS one of
the worst things to happen in this
country in many many years going after
evangelicals and Christians and great
Americans of faith
and
they had to pay up and they had to pay
up dearly for it when they got caught
and this is the same guy
deranged Jack Smith and I watched them
yesterday go up and talk he talked for
about two and a half minutes he was
shaking he was so scared
he didn't want to be there
because ultimately these are cowards
they're cowards
and he's a big Trump hater openly he's a
trump hater and his wife is even more of
a trump hater
I wish her a lot of luck but he's he's a
bad Trump hater and she's a Trumpeter
and you shouldn't put people like that
in and you know the people looking at
Biden is a very nice man they looked at
Mike Pence he had classified documents
no problem
they looked at Biden he has so many
classified documents they don't know
what to do and he's trying to prevent
them from seeing it
that's obstruction
but we didn't do any obstruction this is
a sick nest of people that needs to be
cleaned out immediately get them out
we now have two standards of Justice in
our country the Democrat Communists want
to jailed their opponents while they
protect the murderers who prowl our
cities day and night
and other Brazen criminals I mean what's
happening to your
beautiful Atlanta is so horrible so
horrible people are afraid to walk
outside and no criminal is more
protected than crooked Joe Biden you
know I retired the word crooked from
Hillary
because Hillary doesn't matter anymore
and we're using it on
by
because in history there's never been a
president so corrupt
and thing after thing
Jamie Comer
Jim Jordan the things that those
committees are finding are incredible
and nobody wants to do anything about it
they wanted they they say we've caught
them here five million here five million
there 2 million here
getting paid massive amounts of money to
be on the board of an energy company and
admitting he knows nothing about energy
it's really very sad
it's no coincidence they indicted me the
very same day that it was revealed that
the FBI hit explosive evidence that Joe
Biden took a 5 million dollar
illegal bribe from Ukraine
right now we don't have any ammunition
Ukraine has our ammunition all of it
just about
think of it I rebuilt our military we
had so much ammunition
we were stuffed to the gills as the
expression goes with ammunition and now
we have very little ammunition to
protect ourselves
and then you see that he's getting
large amounts of money from Ukraine and
then you wonder why are we doing this
and by the way that war I'd have it
negotiated at an end it's a horrible
thing in 24 hours
between zelinski and Putin 24 hours says
oh you don't mean that no I'd have that
thing done in 24 hours
right as they're closing on Hunter and
Joe Biden there closing in right now
they say let's do this let's go after
Trump that'll take a lot of the
publicity away we're too hot
that's what they did next Hunter will
probably be charged with some very minor
offense so that the FBI and daoj can
pretend that they're Fair they want to
pretend they're Fair we got Hunter
for jaywalking
while they ignore the bribery money
laundering and other massive crimes
implicating
crooked Joe Biden
right here in Georgia you have a
lunatic Marxist district attorney of
Atlanta who they say is coming after me
over a perfect phone call
in fact this call was even more perfect
than the call I made to president
zielinski of Ukraine this one is
actually more perfect
where I'm complaining about the results
of the election because I thought the
election was I thought the results were
ridiculous and so do many of the people
in this world
and if you look at the numbers and if
you look at the sheets which sadly
judges don't want to do and a lot of
people don't want to do but when you
look at it you look at
truth to vote when you look at other
things with the stuffing of the ballot
boxes when you look at some of the data
that came out and these this election
2020 but elsewhere
we have a long way to go in Georgia they
tell you you don't but you do you have a
very very long way to go I had every
right to complain
that the election in Georgia was in my
opinion rigged that the election in
Georgia was a disaster
I mean you had a
recent election
where
Jody Heist Congressman very popular
congressman
ran and he was leading in virtually
every poll
where's Jody oh Jody stand up look at
Jody
whoa
wow
but Jody's a better person than me
because I really complain like Al Jody
says well
we'll get them next time but you know
what Jody that was a bad bad deal
because you were leading in was it every
single poll
and leading by a lot and the only
question was whether or not you were to
get 50 percent or 49 50 percent there'd
be no runoff 49 there's a runoff
and not only didn't he get 50 and the
other person that you're running against
Brad was very low on the polls and those
polls that we have some of the pollsters
here by the way they they still can't
believe it but Jody uh
ended up with the number what was your
final number Jody
yeah around 37 percent
and the other gentleman got 51 right 51
no runoff
[Applause]
[Music]
and then David Perdue was not losing by
much he was losing the in the polls but
he wasn't losing by much and on Election
Day he was wiped out he lost by
numbers that nobody ever thought
possible very very unfair
look we have to have honest elections we
we just have to or you don't have you
don't have a country you don't have a
state you don't have a country you don't
have anything remember
there was a so-called
water main break that never happened
remember the water main break
think of that the water main breaks we
got a break let's get in there
but that'll be coming up later as time
goes by
remember the tape then you have true to
the vote
found that Georgia
was one of the most egregious states in
the nation
thousands and thousands and thousands of
tapes showing a thing called good
old-fashioned right ballot stuffing good
old-fashioned ballot stuffing in Atlanta
people are afraid to walk to their local
grocery store for a loaf of bread for
fear of being assaulted or murdered
and yet
your local district attorney Fannie
Willis is spending all of her energy all
of her money all of her time trying to
get Trump let's get Trump
yeah you know you're setting or per
capita Atlanta is about the most
dangerous city in the country can you
believe it and people are leaving in
droves
I loved Atlanta
but they're leaving in droves because
it's too unsafe
and they spend all their money trying to
everything this the not the number of
lawyers they got murderers that don't
even get
talked about they get they have
murderers
that that nobody even cares about the
numbers are astronomical
beaten up
that's horrible and they want to go into
a phone call by the way you know one
thing interesting about the phone call
it was perfect I have a right to
complain about the election would
Marjorie Taylor agree where was Marjorie
where's Marjorie
Marjorie Taylor green is here she would
say
hello Marjorie
she's a warrior oh there she is oh look
at her how beautiful
[Applause]
you want to say something come on say
something
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to let you all know and this is
something that you know this is
something that I know president Trump is
beating Joe Biden poll after poll after
poll
[Applause]
seven points today
and if he were to run against Kamala
Harris he's up 11 points which is funny
all right Georgia let's get the job done
in 24 let's get president Trump across
the line let's get him back in the white
house for four more years
thank you
I just wish it was a little bit more
aggressive
now she's great she loves the country
she loves this state
she loves her District she's uh
incredible and she wins her District by
incredible numbers
in the past three years I remember one
thing you know when we talk about this
phone call is perfect it was perfect I
was complaining about the vote Jody's
heard it 10 times
but you know when you talk about the
phone call I had many lawyers for the
state and others on the other side right
Bruce I had many lawyers on the other
side listening and I'd lose them I said
there were many people in the call now
I'm supposed to be a very smart person
number one I wouldn't do it anyway but I
sure as hell wouldn't do it with like
many people on the line but here's
here's what happened
so this only came up much later
we talked they talked we talked I talked
about how I thought the election was
rigged how I thought it was terrible and
everything else Brad rothensberg was on
the line and a whole team
and a whole team of lawyers here's the
main look think of this the call is
perfect
but no of none of those lawyers they
were state lawyers big ones the biggest
ones they didn't say Sir what you said
is inappropriate sir you must
immediately take that back sir
we cannot go any further with this call
unless you take it back what you said is
horrible
we want to indict you for what you said
sir
it was just that no they just talked
in fact we agreed to talk the next day
because they knew I was not happy about
an election that was rigged and you know
when you had a couple of months later
the two senators going up a lot of our
supporters said we're not going to vote
because they didn't feel good about what
happened they knew they saw all those
red hats and all those bandanas and all
the all that stuff that's going in with
make America great again America first
they've never seen anything like it and
they were lost by a whisker but but
remember this on the call I say it now
nobody complained it was a long time
afterwards nobody said oh that was and
if they were going to play and they have
to complain against me they have to say
why did you say that sir why did you say
that you know they're so virgin there's
such babies I'm sorry they couldn't
stand
no if they heard something wrong they
would have had an obligation to tell me
on the phone
nobody said that you listen to the tape
we just continued a conversation there
was nothing that was said wrong I was
complaining
about an election that I think was
rigged and the day that you're not
allowed to comply to the proper
Authority and the day that you're not
allowed to complain an election then we
are indeed communist China
but just remember that for the reporters
and the fake news you got a lot of fake
news back there a lot of people back
there a lot of people outside
but for the fake news back there nobody
complained about the call nobody said oh
this is a terrible thing what you said
sir is breaks my heart to hear this sir
it breaks my heart now these are
professionals they're very good actually
what they do for a lot of other reasons
perhaps but these are professionals
these are lawyers these were people that
would have spoken up even my people
would have spoken up Sarah sorry you're
not allowed to say that or you shouldn't
say that nobody spoke up there were many
lawyers on the line of many people it's
just ridiculous what's going on in the
meantime Atlanta has the highest
per capita rate of crime as I told you
the highest
just about the worst in the entire
nation for people getting murdered
and those people go free but they're
looking for Trump because of a perfect
phone call
you have 71 percent if you think of it
71 percent
right now increase from last year 71
percent increase in homicides in Atlanta
and it now ranks among the highest
murder rates anywhere in the nation
and all they want to do is persecute
Republicans
and a person named Trump who did a great
job as president I have to say
but it's very much like the Attorney
General of New York and the district
attorney of Manhattan
and everybody roll these legal pundits a
lot of them are really good and that
they're saying what a ridiculous
indictment that was that was the
craziest indictment they've ever seen
there's no crime
in fact they said if he lost he gets no
jail I think it is this is what they're
doing and they're going to spend 200
million dollars on prosecuting
a crime where this no crime there was no
crime nothing done there either
but they just want to get Donald Trump
the Attorney General of New York Leticia
James she campaigned I will get Trump
we're going to get him with it she
doesn't even know me never met her
never met the young lady
we're gonna get her
he's
he said peek-a-boo James
no that's not nice Bruce
no but
think of it she campaigned we are going
to get Donald Trump if I win we're going
to get him she knew nothing about me I
have a great company I built an
unbelievable company that's their
problem we built a company that's
really valuable but private you don't
talk about it and uh
unbelievable company and but they're
going to get Donald Trump paid millions
and millions and millions of dollars in
taxes in New York
Meg and act get me now these are sick
people these are sick people our law
enforcement has become weaponized at a
level never seen before the stakes of
this election could not be more Stark
either we have a deep state
or we have a democracy we're going to
have one or the other and we're right at
the Tipping Point right now we're way
leaning toward deep state but deep State
isn't strong enough it's really a
communist country amongst this country
deep State's not strong enough deep
State now is a nice term
compared to what we're doing
either we have a failed country or we
have a free and successful country
and either they win or we win it's very
simple they win or we win
[Applause]
now when I look at Atlanta when I see
what happened to Atlanta over a very
short period of time and then you know
you have these people looking at this
junk but when I look at what happened to
Atlanta in terms of safety this was a
great City at one point and now people
are fleeing Atlanta and they're fleeing
New York and they're fleeing Chicago and
they're fling Los Angeles they're fling
democrat-run cities essentially San
Francisco one of the greatest cities in
the world and now it's seriously
troubled at the end of the day either
the
Communists win and Destroy America
or we destroy
the Communists because that's what they
are they may go by a different name
fascists Marxist
never forget
what they demented
persecution of our movement
is all about It's A demented persecution
our enemies are desperate to stop us
because they know that we we
are the only ones
who are going to be able to stop them we
stopped them we had them stopped called
then they cheated like a bunch of dogs
on the election
I promise you this and I say it all the
time we had a great 2016 but we did much
better in 2020 I say it again and again
because the fake news doesn't want to
report that they never want to report it
what happened in 2020 I said well I got
millions more votes well I never thought
of it that way sir let's get to another
question
if you put me back in the White House
their rain will be over in America will
be a free Nation again
[Applause]
thank you
I stand before you today as the only
candidate
who has what it takes to smash this
corrupt system this is a corrupt system
I mean they go after me nobody's ever
been gone after
like we have had that from everybody sir
this has never happened to anybody
now they'll do it to other people if
somebody else is doing what I'm doing
but the other people are going to fold
you know who they are they're going to
fold very quickly we don't fold we don't
fold our tent and go home
and again we want to drain the swamp and
I'm the only one that's going to do it
nobody else is going to do it we know
the competition we know it
anyone else will be absolutely ripped to
shreds these are sick sick Sinister
people it's no wonder
the swamp is getting truly desperate as
they see us leading big pole after big
pole after big Pole in this week's
morning console poll just came out
we lead the field by 34 points
with
trumpet 56.
to sanctimonious at 22.
Pence it seven
Haley at three
in the clarity campaign poll I don't
know that Paul but I love it
it's a big deal actually
a lot of people they interview we're up
by 56 points
Trump is at 69 the sanctimonious is at
13. Pence is at six but Pence has gone
down since his last sadly because he's a
nice person he's trying to get nasty
though so we may have to fight a
different way
all of a sudden you notice that it's all
of a sudden you get a little bit nasty
Mike
in the Emerson poll of Iowa we love Iowa
look we got
28 billion dollars
for the farmers from China
think of it China gave us 28 billion
dollars because they abused our Farmers
throughout the country I got them to pay
28 billion for the farmers and I said
there's no way we're losing Iowa I don't
want to sound too confident
because strange things happen in
politics like you endorse people and
then they run against you two days later
strange things happen you endorse people
you get them elected you get people that
had no chance no chance they're dead
their career is over you get involved
you endorse them you do other things you
get them up they win the election in a
landslide
and then they say we're looking forward
to running against Trump oh that's nice
now they're not looking so forward to it
anymore
but in the Emerson poll of Iowa
we're leading by 42 points
with Trump at 62 percent
and we're leading crooked Joe Biden most
crooked president in the history of our
country
by a lot in the recent Fabrizio swing
state poll of Arizona Georgia Michigan
Pennsylvania Wisconsin we're at almost
50 percent were leading Biden by five
in the ABC Washington Post poll I'm up
by seven points over Biden
and a new poll from democracy Institute
shows I'm the only candidate
who beats crooked Joe that's hard to
believe because frankly who the hell
wouldn't beat him
the country's going to hell
you know they have an automatic
constituency the Democrats it's not that
easy
but the Sanctus loses to him by a lot
with each passing Day More Americans are
joining our patriotic movement together
we have achieved more than any person
ever thought possible and this was
from 2016. when I announced in 2015
everyone said oh what he has no
experience and they were right about
that actually
the hell did I know
I said where the hell is China and then
I proceeded to take more money out of
China's high than any president that is
but we delivered the largest tax cuts
and Regulatory Cuts in history more so
than the Reagan tax cuts which were
great we built the greatest economy in
the history of the world
we achieved energy Independence
soon-to-be energy dominance
for the first time in 64 years
and gas prices were at one dollar and 87
cents a gallon we actually had them
lower than that for a little while but I
had to get them up we were going to lose
the oil companies they were going so low
they were getting Crea they were getting
killed but now they want to give you all
electric cars isn't that wonderful so
you you feel does anybody want to drive
for an hour and then wait four hours to
get a recharge
we'll end that first day in office I'll
be ending all of that
you want an electric car that's great
but if you want other types of vehicles
where you can actually drive for a long
period of time that's good too you're
going to be able to have your choice
and if you want a gas stove or an
electric stove you're going to have your
choice
and if you want to have a dishwasher
that actually lets water come out
[Laughter]
you know I did that
the people came to see me wonderful
people whirlpool and some people they
from Ohio I love Ohio we won Ohio so big
those people are great in Ohio very much
like you actually great people and they
said sir China
and South Korea are dumping washing
machines they're dumping dryers they're
dumping everything they're killing us
we're going to probably go out of
business I met with the chairman of the
company and I said wow that's not good
and I put a big fat tariff of 50 on all
of that stuff and now they're one of the
most thriving
companies
in the country they were going to go out
that's one of the reasons they like me
in Ohio
but we saved it they were really they
were doing it they were selling machines
that weren't as good but they were
selling machines machines for so little
that was very unfair and I think they
were doing it on purpose to drive them
out you know what they do they drive
them out of business then they quadruple
the price and you have to buy their
product because you have no choice I
mean I can't believe they get away with
this stuff but we don't get away with it
with us we created the most secure
Border in U.S history built hundreds of
miles of border wall hundreds and
hundreds of miles
got Mexico to give us 28 000 soldiers
free of charge said to the president I
really like the president of Mexico a
lot he's great he's a socialist but you
can't have everything but we got a long
way
but I said to Mexico you have to you
have to give us 28 000 soldiers on the
border because you're letting a lot of
people in they looked at me like is this
guy crazy
he said no we won't do that one of their
representatives top person good man
the state department left when I said it
a woman was wonderful she said you know
I've been trying to get things like that
for 25 years sir it's not doable I said
you want to bet bet you anything you
want it's doable it's going to be easy
it'll take me minutes it's not doable so
I met with him came in I said we need 28
000 soldiers we want to have a policy of
remain in Mexico we don't want them to
come they're going to remain in Mexico
until they get approved we did the all
sorts of policies having to do with
title 42 you're sick you can't come into
our country all everything but I said
you're going to have to do it he said no
sir we're not going to be doing that I
said here's what I'm doing
I'm putting a 25 tariff on everything
that's sold in Mexico that comes into
our country on Monday morning was Friday
and I'm signing it before your very eyes
here I forget to sign it when you watch
goes into effect on Monday morning this
was on a Friday
I said may I be excused for just a
minute I'd like to make a phone call
I wonder who he called he called my
friend who is really a good person by
the way and loves this country and he
came back into the room within five
minutes and he said sir would be our
honor to give you 28 000 soldiers
and we had the safest border
in the history of our country by far and
that means drugs and human trafficking
which is mostly in women I hate to say
human trafficking you know you think of
it as an ancient crime it's not it's
very the internet's made it bigger than
it's ever been but we stopped we put
that to a level that hasn't been seen in
decades and drugs were down now they're
11 times more than coming in just three
11 times more they're pouring in
fentanyl
and we terminated another thing called
Catch and Release we catch them in our
country and then we release them in our
country what a great policy Catch and
Release we ended that think of it catch
and release of Democrats you catch him
in the United States they could be the
worst criminals you've ever seen and we
release them in the United States I said
what the hell kind of a policy is that
so that ended also we did a great job
but just as I promised I ended the
disaster known as NAFTA the worst trade
deal ever made and replace it with the
usmca the best trade deal perhaps ever
made
and a massive victory for our farmers
and for your Georgia Farmers and your
manufacturers USMC you know how I know
it's great because they want to
renegotiate the deal Mexico and Canada
they want to renegotiate the deal
they're trying to renegotiate it with
the Biden Administration
and I just say to those in the Biden
Administration all of whom are listening
right now by the way don't do it
don't do it they took advantage of us
for years and years now we have a deal
where frankly it's a much better deal
for us than it is for them don't
renegotiate the deal
it's great though what we did is great
isn't it nice where they want to
renegotiate a deal for a chance because
these countries always rip us off we I
used to look at some of the deals that
were made they were so bad I said do
these people like our country that are
making these horrible deals I stood up
to China like no Administration has ever
done before and I made people aware that
China was ripping us off nobody knew
that they said oh China's so wonderful
bringing hundreds of billions of dollars
pouring into the treasury from China
with taxes and tariffs when no other
president had ever gotten 10 cents not
10 cents from China
working with our secretary of
agriculture Sonny Perdue from your state
good man
we negotiated more than 50 trade
agreements to boost exports by billions
and billions of dollars for the American
Farmer we appointed nearly 300 federal
judges and three great Supreme Court
Justices
gotten some great rulers
oh they would go crazy every time
they saw me appointing a Supreme Court
judge
I fully rebuilt the U.S military we had
more ammunition than at any time and as
I said before now we have almost none I
imposed a powerful travel ban to keep
radical Islamic terrorists
in radical jihadists the hell out of our
country
we took a lot of heat they said no let
them come in oh really why do you want
them to come in why do you want them to
come in let them come in why Chelsea
please tell me why
and
if you just take a look at those four
years how did we do on that front we did
great
we accomplished all of this and More in
just that short period of time and just
imagine
what we can accomplish in the next four
years we can make our country greater
than ever before
we have some big obstacles one of the
biggest obstacles I think is that we
will have I believe 15 million people in
our country from
prisons and mental institutions and
everything you know we gotta some rough
ones some real rough ones we got to get
them out we will do it we got to get
them out
here's just some of the Bold agenda I'll
put
into effect when we become the 47th
president of the United States
before I even arrive at the Oval Office
shortly after I win the presidency I
will have the horrible war between
Russia and Ukraine settled and we'll do
it quickly
know them both very well we'll get it
done fast would have never happened if I
was President by the way all those
people that are dead would be alive
today
all those cities that are burned and
shot to the ground
missiles going into every building
knocking the hell out of them and then
they say two people were hurt no many
many people were killed the numbers are
far worse than you hear about
you see him knock out like 12 missiles
going to buildings collapsing all over
the place and they say two people were
injured no no hundreds and even
thousands of people were killed in those
attacks individually and uh hundreds of
thousands of people are being killed
I'll get it done very quickly before I
ever get to office you need the power
of the Oval Office to be able to do it
you need that but I'll get it done very
quickly if it's still going on which is
hard to believe it could continue
it's a horrible horrible disgusting War
I'm the only candidate who can make this
promise
I will prevent World War III I will
prevent it and now people believe it too
and without me it will happen
and this won't be a conventional war
with army tanks going back and forth
shooting each other this will be nuclear
war this will be
obliteration
perhaps obliteration of the entire world
I will prevent it nobody else can say
that I know all the players
I deal with them and I dealt with them
very successfully and they respected
your president and they respected your
country
and now they don't have any respect for
your president or your country
to stop the Marxist prosecutors who
release rapists and murderers while
persecuting conservatives I will direct
a completely over told and this is so
important so important
a completely overhauled doj to
investigate every radical D.A in America
for their illegal racist in Reverse
enforcement
of the law
[Applause]
I will immediately cancel every open
borders policy
of the Biden Administration you can come
into our country but you have to come in
Legally
under Biden other countries are emptying
out their prisons insane asylums and
mental institutions and dumping everyone
right here in the good old USA
following the Eisenhower model people
don't realize but Dwight Eisenhower is
very very tough in this issue the
toughest
very very tough you don't think of them
as being that way but he was very tough
in this issue we will use all necessary
State local Federal and Military
resources to carry out the largest
domestic deportation operation in
American history
when you look at the crime statistics
and you see the crime tremendous amounts
of crime are pouring into our country
but we'll get the bad ones out very fast
you know we'll be working with the local
police they know every bad one
and we're going to give the police back
the respect and honor that they deserve
I will ask every state and federal
agency to identify every known or
suspected gang member in America and
every one of them that is here illegally
will be picked up
and will be sent back to the country
from which they came
and to further deter illegal immigration
I will sign a day one executive
executive order we're going to do an
executive order day one so important
ending automatic citizenship for
children of illegal aliens
under the Biden Administration
illegal aliens are treated better than
our vets okay not going to happen
and because we're so open armed and
stupid please come they come if you said
you can't come they won't come that's
why I was very successful I said no
we're not going to allow you to come in
and
they really we really had it stopped
nobody's ever seen anything like it I
was talking to Brandon Judd had a border
border patrol and Tom Holman
an absolute classic Tom home and you see
Tom Central Casting but these guys are
total pros and we were talking recently
and they can't believe what's happened
but we could clog it up in about two
weeks and really almost complete the job
because we want people to come into our
country but we want them to come in
Legally we want to know who they are
where they're from what problems do they
bring are they murderers we'd rather not
have you Sarah I'm sorry you murdered
four people if you don't mind we'd
rather not have you
to save our economy from Joe Biden's
inflation catastrophe and economic
disaster I will deliver tax cuts energy
price cuts and interest rates cuts the
likes of which you have never seen
before except in the Trump
Administration actually
we will pass the Trump reciprocal trade
act which means if a foreign country
charges tariffs or taxes on our products
we will charge their products at the
exact same rate it's called an eye for
an eye
[Applause]
now some of these these politicians
India is very high on tariffs and the
China is unbelievably High Brazil is
high a lot of them are high
and I go to some of the politicians we
had a senator from
a great state in Pennsylvania who no
longer ran because I wouldn't give them
the endorsement this guy fought me all
the time I said let me ask you something
to me I said let me ask you to me let me
ask you this question if China's
charging us 150 percent tariff
and we're selling the same product and
we judge them nothing would it be okay
if we judge them 150 no sir that's not
free trade
okay how about they charge us 150 how
about we charge them a hundred percent
no sir how about 50 how about 10 no sir
no sir no sir
I said how stupid is this or
is he representing them in some way
and all I say is reciprocal trade if
they charge us we charge them now what
will happen a lot of them will just drop
it
and if they don't that's okay too
because we'll charge them the same thing
we'll take in billions and billions and
hundreds of billions of dollars
reciprocal trade
I spoke to a couple of senators and then
it's not their thing business is not
their thing and I said uh I described
the reciprocal trade they said okay let
me get this straight so they charge us
right yeah and they charge us and then
we charge them the same thing right if
they don't take it off yeah that's right
you got my vote
pretty simple isn't it
it'll make a difference like you
wouldn't believe and it also bring back
a lot of money into our country a lot of
jobs back into our country but will also
probably be putting a border tax you
know these countries come into
raid our country they steal our country
they're stealing it if you look at
Germany with their cars they don't take
our cars we take their cars and I did a
lot of changes but we have to do
something because they don't take our
cars I asked Angela Merkel Angela how
many Chevrolets you have in the middle
of Berlin why I believe nothing I said
you're right you have nothing how many
mercedes-benzes and BMWs do we have it's
like you can't even see without seeing
them all over our highways they're very
good cars but you know what they've got
to be fair
and they're not fair because they think
we're stupid that's the only reason they
think we're so stupid our leaders have
been stupid for so many years we're
giving away our country we have 36
trillion dollars in debt we can wipe out
that debt by being smart and also by
being energy dominant we will make so
much money we make so much money and
sell it to countries that don't have
liquid gold under their feet we have
more Liquid Gold I call it Liquid Gold
because that's what it's better than
gold we have more Liquid Gold under our
feet than any other country in the world
nobody knows that
I did something called Anwar in Alaska
probably the biggest find ever I think
it's bigger than Saudi Arabia but it's
at least similar but could be bigger the
first day in office
by the way Reagan tried to get it he
couldn't get it done other presidents
tried to get it they couldn't get it
done the first day in office
they terminated it this was going to
make Alaska into something like nobody's
ever seen before but the biggest
beneficiary would have been the United
States of America we would have been
selling that oil to
Japan to China all over the world we
would have been selling it and uh but we
will get that back and we'll do things
but nobody can get it approved friend of
mine called he said I can't believe you
got N word Ronald Reagan could not do it
I will revoke China's most favored
nation trade status can you believe it
they get a most favorable
because they say we're a growing country
we're a developing Nation they call it
we are a developing Nation so we need a
big advantage over the United well we're
a developing Nation also if you think we
are developing we're developing in the
wrong in the wrong way we're going in
the wrong way that's how we're
developing
we're going to turn it around
I will gain total independence from
China and we'll work with China we'll
have a great relation I had a great
relationship with President XI until
covet hit our Shores and that was just
too much we actually made an incredible
trade deal with China I don't even talk
about it because covet was so bad what
came out of Wuhan the Wuhan Labs that I
said that right from the beginning I
never changed just like I was right
about live golf was I right about live
golf I was right I said you better make
a deal
you guys the golfers you better make a
deal
I was right I called that one exactly
right didn't I because if they merge if
you don't make a deal you're not going
to get anything
and a lot of guys got left out in the
cold but I call this one much more
importantly I called this one and I'll
hold the Chinese Communist Party
accountable for unleashing the China
virus upon the world
and unlike my competitor who I got
elected by the way
Rhonda sanctimonious
who voted to gut Medicare
and voted to gut Social Security three
times
and to raise the retirement age to 70.
that's a big increase
I will always protect Medicare and
social security for our great nation
you know it's one thing about a
politician they can lie during a
campaign but you know when a guy wanted
to
decapitate Medicare and Social Security
and you earn those things you know you
earn them for a long time you've earned
them but when a guy wants to do it and
then they run and they say no we're you
know we don't want to do it we're only
kidding no we don't want to do it they
always go back to doing it I see that
with politicians it's sort of like when
somebody's a never Trumper
and then we win and they come and they
just absolutely kiss my ass please
please sir please
I I I love you very much I love you so
we give them a shot they always end up
being a never jumper I don't know when
they're bad they're bad but the truth is
with politicians and I did know
politicians long before I actually
officially ran for office because I
dealt with a lot of politicians but when
a politician has an idea to
hurt Social Security make the age 70
hurt Medicare
a hundred percent they go back to it
after the election 100 percent so you
can vote for Ron to sanctimonious
because he voted three times to destroy
he also
wants to put a national sales tax of 23
percent on all of our citizens
and you don't want that that's very bad
for
people that don't have a lot of money
you're going to be paying the same sales
taxes rich people I don't think that's
going to work too well but he wanted to
do that and he fought hard to do it
because he's a disciple of Paul Ryan and
Paul Ryan is a disaster
you can't let you don't want any
Disciples of Paul Ryan I will
immediately sign a new executive order
to cut Federal funding for any school
pushing critical race Theory transgender
insanity
and other inappropriate racial sexual or
political content on our children
and likewise I will immediately take
care of this I will keep men out of
women's sports
and who believes I even have to say this
can you imagine having to say this where
did this country go where did our minds
go they got blown up by drugs or
something I will sign a law prohibiting
child sexual mutilation in all 50 cents
now can you believe it
sexual mutilation
and one of the big things I hate to even
say because it's so ridiculous can you
imagine saying this 10 15 years ago I
will give you back your parental rights
parental rights who wouldn't have
parental rights can you believe you have
to even say this I will give you back
your parental rights
if they could have gone back 15 years
and somebody heard that statement being
made they say no no that's crazy to make
a statement like that of course I have
parental rights you could have your
parental rights back in addition I will
not give one penny to any school
that has a vaccine mandate or mask
mandate from kindergarten through Power
and as I announce this week to continue
my long record of standing up to Big
farmer I will establish a special
presidential commission to investigate
what is causing the decades-long
increase in childhood diseases
autoimmune disorders autism obesity
infertility and other chronic health
problems where is it all coming from
where is it all coming from we started a
big program but
they ended it very quickly where is it
all coming from to uphold our Second
Amendment or I'll ask Congress to put a
bill on my desk delivering National
concealed carry reciprocity
and I will protect innocent life just as
I did before strong years
Four Strong years
bring back
free speech in America that's what we
have to do we're going to bring back
Free Speech right now we're
a country that doesn't know what's
happening we're a country that hasn't
been given free speech and when you
watch the cover-up of the fake news
media of crimes that are being had where
Biden steals money and they don't want
to have it this would have been the
biggest story 20 25 years ago maybe much
closer than that the things that they're
revealing and are being revealed would
have been Front Page News everybody
would have wanted a fake Pulitzer Prize
because a Pulitzer Prize deal is fake
how about this I'm suing the Pulitzer
Foundation because
they gave the Pulitzer Prize to
reporters for their accurate and
magnificent and beautiful reporting on
Russia Russia Russia they were exactly
wrong it was a hoax so therefore they
should give back to the Pulitzer prizes
so let's see how that one turns out
there they got a tough one there they
gave out the Pulitzer Prize to people
that wrote about Russia Russia for their
wonderful reporting they were exactly
wrong on their reporting so we'll see
how that turns out
finally to restore pride in
our history and confidence in our future
I will lead a massive year-long salute
to America to celebrate the 250th
anniversary of July 4th 1776.
[Applause]
July 4th
1776 big big time
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you that's nice to hear
that
some people like to use other dates
you don't mind I'm going to stick with
that one is that okay
this is what we must do to restore our
country to Greatness the USA is a mess
our economy is crashing inflation is out
of control China Russia Iran North Korea
have formed together and there are
menacing and destructive
Coalition and force our currency is
crashing and will soon no longer be the
world standard that's like losing a war
it'll be the greatest defeat for our
country in 200 years if that happens
people don't know how big that is
but it won't happen with me not even a
chance just like Russia would never have
happened with Ukraine and China would
not
even being having a thought about
raiding Taiwan some Democrats said last
week well how do we know
and this
wonderful announcer this wonderful
pundit said well he was there four years
we never heard anything about it they
never talked about it I talked to Putin
I talked to president XI President Putin
I said you're not going to do it they
never even brought it up now as soon as
I leave that's they've got bombers
flying over Taiwan Ukraine is one of the
worst things anyone's ever seen it's
just a mess what a shame what a shame
what a shame all those lives are lost
if you took the worst
five presidents in the history of the
United States and added them up they
would not have done near the destruction
to our country as Joe Biden and the
Biden Administration have done that
wouldn't it
what they've done to our country
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation in Decline
and now these radical left lunatics want
to interfere with our elections by using
law enforcement we're not going to let
it happen
it's totally corrupt and we can't let it
happen
this is the final battle this is the
most important election we've ever had
with you at my side we will demolish
the Communists the fascists the marxists
the Deep state
whatever you want to call them we will
expel the war mongers from our
government let's start a war every week
else start a war
we don't want Wars
we can't afford Wars and we don't want
death we want to keep people living
whether it's here or other countries we
don't want to kill people for no reason
we will drive out the globalists
we will cast out the Communists we will
throw off the sick
political class that hates our country
and wants to destroy our country we will
route the fake news media
they don't want to talk about anything
if the Democrats do something bad they
don't they will not write it you know
you can't have a scandal if the fake
news won't talk about it they don't want
to talk about it the job that they're
doing in Congress is so amazing
Jamie and Jim and all of the people
together
but the news doesn't want to pick it up
these are the biggest scandals ever in
the history of our country
we're a president of the United States
is being paid off
and to try and deflect that he said
let's try and arrest
a president that served before him and
had
an unbelievable success record a record
like
really very few presidents if any have
ever had Over a four-year period think
of it and then we get 12 to 14 million
more votes than
we got the first time
and they were saying that if you get the
same 63 million votes sir
you can't lose the pulses are right
there sitting right there you can't lose
sir
well we got millions and millions of
more votes and they say we lose but we
didn't lose you know that and this they
use covet to cheat they use covet to
cheat mail-in ballots by the way will
always be dishonest Jimmy Carter
uh
uh very nice man he had a commission and
his commission said the one thing please
please never use mail-in ballots
the elections will be fraudulent France
went to paper ballots same-day voting
voter ID
36 million people voting recently by 10
o'clock in the evening the election was
over you had a winner you had a loser
and that was the end of it
and they used to do mail-in ballots but
they ended it because it was so corrupt
it's going to be corrupt whether it's I
would never say this about our mailman
because we love our mailmen but whether
it's the mailman or all the many people
that touched those ballots they find
them in rivers they find them in streams
they find them all over the place
many people got many ballots you all
know the stories everyone knows and the
Democrats know it's no good
but France ended at many other countries
ended it
in Canada they do a different system
they have paper ballots
so we have to think about that because
again you don't have borders you don't
have Fair elections you don't have a
country you don't have a country we'll
expose the Rhinos we'll defeat Joe Biden
and we will liberate America from these
villains once and for all the silent
majority is rising and under our
leadership the Forgotten men and women
will never
be forgotten again they're never going
to be forgotten again
we said that in 2016.
and you know in 2016 the Border was a
big issue and I did such a good job that
in 2020 we couldn't mention the Border
because nobody thought about the Border
because we had such a good border can
you believe it I used to talk about the
border the border the Border everybody
would fall asleep
because we had the strongest border the
most secure border that we've ever had
in the history of our country and
now it's worse than it's ever been
this makes 2016 when I took over it
looked like Child's Play
and we're not going to let it happen
we're not going to let millions of
people come come into our country that
shouldn't be here
with your help your love and your
prayers
we will make America great again and I
just want to thank the great people of
Georgia you've been an incredible state
for me and so many friends
and I want to see you live
and enjoy your stay
we don't want to see people murdered
many a day we don't want to see it we
want strength we want to pay great
respect to our police we want to cherish
our police and our firemen and all the
people that make it safe not destroy
their lives if they happen to
do something that perhaps because they
make mistakes and there's always some
bad ones no matter what you do
but we cannot let our country go to hell
these cities are
worse than War zones
we have to let the police do the job
that they know how to do and they know
how to do it brilliantly but we have to
cherish them we have to make them Heroes
again
we have to make them Heroes again so for
Atlanta and from all of these cities all
of these cities all over the country
that are rotting away and becoming
cesspools of murder
we're going to do something that's going
to be very strong
and we're going to stop the crime wave
because this crime wave will not let our
country exist you can't lose these great
cities these great powerful beautiful
cities with Gorgeous buildings and all
of the things and right down on the
sidewalk
everybody's being murdered and beat up
and mugged we're not going to let it
happen thank you very much everybody
it's a great honor to be here thank you
thank you